was genau befindet sich eigentlich am
rand unseres sonnensystems eine äußerst
spannende frage zu der forschungsteams
weltweit tüfteln jetzt hat die nasa eine
erfolgsmeldung in diesem zusammenhang
ausgaben denn ihre sonde new horizons
hat wohl diese lang gesuchte struktur
aufgespürt die grenze zwischen unserem
sonnensystem und dem interstellaren raum
alle infos dazu bekommt ihr jetzt mal
klick zum science fiction herzlich
willkommen und damit herzlich willkommen
zum ersten werbefreien video hier auf
klicks um tausend dank an alle
mitglieder des kanals die das möglich
gemacht haben wie zum beispiel steven
maurer mitglied werden könnt erfahrt ihr
am ende des videos
die nasa sonde new horizons war im
januar 2006 gestartet um unter anderem
den pluto zu erforschen aber auch die
genaue untersuchung der heliosphäre
steht auf ihrem plan
damit ist die atmosphäre der sonne
gemeint die eine große region um die
sonne bezeichnet in der sonnenwind samt
seiner magnetfelder wirksam ist die
äußerste grenze der heliosphäre ist die
sogenannte heliopause oft auch als
grenze unseres sonnensystems bezeichnet
und dahinter beginnt dann laut
definition der interstellaren raum new
horizons ist derzeit jedenfalls auf dem
weg zur grenze unseres sonnensystems
dieses zu passieren dass haben bisher
nur die beiden voyager sonden geschafft
und das will schon was heißen denn es
müssen nicht nur gigantische dimensionen
entfernungen überwunden werden sondern
auch die gravitation der sonne dazu
hatten die deutsche sondern mehrere
swing by manöver durchgeführt und
insgesamt haben sie für die ganze
mission mehr als 25 jahre gedacht wow
und schon damals hatte deutsche
entdeckung gemacht die auf das ende
unseres sonnensystems hinweisen genau
wie jetzt new horizons in den jahren
2007 und 2017 die sondelfinger einen
ultravioletten schimmer 1
nach ansicht der forschungsteams wohl
von solaren photonen produziert die auf
wasserstoffatome treffen und sich
zerstreuen schon damals gab es die
theorie dass es sich bei dieser
gigantischen struktur am rande unseres
sonnensystems um eine wasserstoff wand
handeln könnte und auch auf eine
aktuelle aufnahme hat ein nasa
forschungsteam jetzt ein ultraviolettes
leuchten ende also ein weiteres starkes
indiz dafür
eine wasserstoff wand als das ende des
sonnensystems spricht doch wie entsteht
das ultraviolette leuchten dazu schreibt
das nasa forschungsteam das beobachtete
ultraviolette licht ist nicht nur das
ergebnis der zerstreuung das sonnenlicht
durch wasserstoff atome im sonnensystem
sondern deutet auch auf eine entfernte
quelle in die entfernte quellen könnte
der beweis für eine band aus wasserstoff
sein die in der nähe der stelle entdeckt
wurde wo der interstellare wind mit dem
sonnenwind in berührung kommt also noch
mal im klartext sonnenwinde entstehen
dadurch dass die sonne ständig geladene
teilchen ausstrahlt dieser teilchenstrom
samt seinem magnetfeld erzeugt die
heliosphäre der teilchenstrom der sonne
verdrängt hier das interstellare medium
doch mit zunehmendem abstand von der
sonne wird der sonnenwind
verständlicherweise immer schwächer er
kann dann den strom interstellarer
teilchen nicht mehr stoppen
hier befindet sich eine art grenze ihre
außenseite zeigt in die richtung in der
sich die sonne durchs all bewegt genau
hier kommt es dann zum stau von
interstellarer materie die auch
wasserstoff enthält wenn diese
wasserstoff atome dann auf geladene
partikel aus dem sonnenwind treffen
senden sie und ra violettes licht aus
doch der endgültigen beweis für diese
wasserstoff wand der steht noch aus so
die nasa denn das ultraviolette licht
könnte theoretisch auch noch aus anderen
quellen in den tiefen der galaxis
stammen doch genau das soll new horizons
jetzt ausschließen und weiter nach dem
schimmern ausschau halten wenn das
ultraviolette licht aber weiterhin
bestehen bliebe handele es sich wohl um
eine quelle vor der sonne und sei dann
nicht als hinweis auf das ende unseres
sonnensystems zu deuten so und jetzt
könnt ihr krieg zum weiter werbefrei
machen keine privates mehr mit eurer
hilfe
immer wenn wir entsprechend viele kanal
mitglieder gewonnen haben schalten wir
die werbung vor jeweils einem video im
monat ab das hier ist das erste video
und es werden mehr werdet also mitglied
hier unter dem video
draufklicken und bekommt noch exklusive
extra videos exklusive live streams und
noch ein paar weitere privilegien einen
diesen dank all diejenigen die schon
dabei sind wenn er immer garantiert über
aktuelle videos informiert werden
wollten dann endet mich übrigens bei
whatsapp dann bekommt ihr den link zum
video vor allen andern von mir
persönlich auf euer handy einfach hier
draufklicken und darunter geht es weiter
mit dem auftreten erster interstellare
mission verlässt unserem sonnensystem
bis dann bleibt dran